[Musique]
habitants du nord des Yvelines attention
plusieurs rôtis de la marque valgrin
sont rappelés en raison de la présence
de salmonelle il s'agit du rôti savoyard
livré à Carrières-sur-Seine au Relais
Des italiers du rôti de pruneaux livrés
aux Mureaux à l'entrepôt du rôti façon
Orloff livré au Carrefour de Chambourcy
au BDM d'Orgeval et aux Mureaux et des
rôties provençal et chèvres miel livrés
au BDM d'Orgeval le parti politique
d'Eric Zemmour reconquête organisait
samedi dernier une manifestation devant
le domaine de Grignon les partisans
dénoncent la mise en place d'un centre
d'hébergement d'urgence pour 200
migrants indignaient une trentaine
d'habitants de la ville de thivernal
Grignon se sont rendus sur place pour
une contre manifestation il n'y a pas eu
de débordement on poursuit avec le
chiffre du jour 25000 il s'agit du
nombre de signalements de coupure
internet dans les Yvelines sur l'année
2022 le département serait le cinquième
territoire de France avec le plus grand
nombre de pannes les chiffres de zone
ADSL le spécialiste du très haut débit
les causes travaux dégradation
intempéries mauvais entretien ou encore
mauvais branchement guettez votre boîte
mail et vos indésirables si vous vous
êtes inscrit pour le tirage au sort de
la billetterie des Jeux olympiques de
Paris 2024 vous allez peut-être être
parmi les chanceux jusqu'au 15 mars vous
pourrez recevoir une notification pour
acheter des billets en pack pour 3
disciplines olympiques prix mini 24
euros prix maxi 690 euros soyez aux
aguets vous n'aurez que 48 heures pour
effectuer la demande et enfin les fans
de jeux vidéo avaient rendez-vous samedi
au Palais des Sports Pierre de Coubertin
de plaisir la ville organisait la
deuxième édition du plaisir gaming au
programme plusieurs tournois sur PC et
console fortnite FIFA ou encore super
smash bros j'étais déjà venu l'année
dernière et c'est il y a clairement une
grande amélioration là il y a beaucoup
plus de monde il y a beaucoup plus de
joueurs
où ma mère et mon père ou ma maman et
mon papa jouait et puis on est à Just
Dance pour ceux qui aiment bien danser
un ancien gamer entre guillemets j'ai
beaucoup joué étrangère et puis bah je
viens ici pour redécouvrir un peu les
anciennes consoles les nouveaux jeux
cette seconde édition a attiré plus de
1000 personnes la ville de Plaisir
penche déjà sur une troisième édition
[Musique]